was wir heute erlebt haben ist ein
angriff an der raketenangriff ganz in
der nähe von nato gebiet das kann man
sozusagen sehen von nato gebiet von der
polnischen grenze aus 20 kilometer ins
land rein dort sind die raketen
explodiert heute in aller frühe ist das
ein weiterer test für uns alle für die
nato wie stehen wir zusammen und wann
müssen wir da eingreifen auf der einen
seite ist es sicherlich ein test und auf
der anderen seite ist es etwas womit wir
auch immer rechnen müssen denn im kern
geht es ja um militärgebiet es geht um
lagerhallen es geht um vielleicht
objekte wo waffen gelagert werden und
die russische armee prüft genau auch
über geheimdienste in der region wo sind
lohnenswerte ziele und deswegen muss man
auch mit solchen ja anschlägen so nenne
ich jetzt mal auch wenn es taktische
raketen waren nennen gehen sie davon aus
dass das eine umschlagplatz war
sozusagen für waffenlieferungen von uns
von nato partnern in die ukraine ich
kann das so nicht sagen aber dass
zumindest die russischen streitkräfte
das vermuten das liegt aus meiner sicht
nahe denn schon in der ersten welle war
es ja so dass man sich auf militär
gebiete auf flugplätze und vieles mehr
konzentriert hat und deswegen ist mehr
oder weniger jede kaserne jeder
übungsplatz jede lagerhalle die den
militärischen anschein hat auch für
lagerung von waffen oder ausbildungs
verfügung zu stehen ein potenzielles
ziel sie reagieren das will ich ihnen
gar nicht unterstellen nicht ohne
emotional aber ja doch relativ gelassen
bei dieser sache sie sagen das ist halt
im moment das was passiert man stelle
sich das umgekehrt vor das würde direkt
vor der russischen haustür passieren 20
kilometer vor der russischen grenze
würden raketen von nato-partnern
einschlagen das wäre natürlich eine ganz
andere dimension da gebe ich ihnen recht
und das ist natürlich das emotional
diskutiert wird es auch richtig aber wir
versuchen natürlich immer sehr sachlich
die dinge zu sehen auch wenn unser herz
mehr oder weniger bei den ukrainern ist
wir erleben ja hier was in berlin
passiert ankommende flüchtlinge wir
leben von ihrer berichterstattung aber
auch über die geheimdienstberichte was
in den städten passiert stichwort
humanitäre katastrophe mario polen etc
und natürlich sehen wir wie sich die
schlinge um kiew beispielsweise zurzeit
nichts desto trotz ist es so dass wir
sehr sachlich agieren müssen damit
rechnen müssen wir wissen putin hat
taktische ziele das sind die
verkehrsknotenpunkte
operative ziele das sind die
verwaltungszentren die städte da kommt
dann nicht richtig vorwärts und dann
gibts auch dass eine andere operative
ziel wie jetzt in der nähe von limburg
er versucht ja weiter strategisch nicht
nur uns mit blick auf die energiepreise
zu treffen sondern eben auch zutreffen
blick auf die flüchtlingsbewegung und
jede rakete die irgendwo einschlägt
sorgt für mehr bewegung und das wird
unsere größte hat ja vor allem dort in
lemberg das geld doch so ein bisschen
als sicherer hafen innerhalb der ukraine
viele sind nicht raus aus der ukraine
sondern innerhalb der ukraine erst mal
geflüchtet und haben dauert eben in der
region lemberg oder in der stadt
zuflucht gesucht und genau dort vor der
stadt schlagen also heute die raketen
ein und gleichzeitig ist das
möglicherweise ein weiterer funken oder
wir sind auf dem weg zu dem fünkchen der
dann ja den konflikt den krieg weiter
ausweitet wie dicht stehen wir da vor
und was ist dieser funken also
beispielsweise gab es heute eine meldung
dass dort auf diesem militärflughafen
auf dieser militärbasis auf
nato ausbilder
tätig waren das ist ja schon sehr sehr
dicht an einem solchen fünkchen naja
dass er demoralisieren will mit diesen
angriffen in der jeweiligen ukrainischen
bevölkerung das ist vollkommen klar und
was die schnittstellen anbelangt da muss
man aufpassen das ist schon manchmal
fließend und deswegen muss die nato muss
der westen einen kühlen kopf bewahren
denn nochmal der schritt dann in
richtung eskalationsspirale die wir
nicht aufhalten können der ist dann
relativ klein und deswegen ist mir
lieber einmal mehr telefonieren einmal
mehr auf die sachlage schauen bevor man
über reagiert weil dann kommen wir zu
einem szenario das wollen wir uns nicht
vorstellen